hello today we're going to smash an
apple no apple golf again
no aah an apple now before everyone goes
mental
this is actually a really old PowerBook
g4 that doesn't work so I sell that I
love all the old connectors on it
what is that yes sir DVI what is that
what George do this one I will actually
write all right enough of smashing Apple
oh bloody yeah yeah
is that is it
huh
okay let me walk you through our path of
destruction here the keyboard is
actually quite resilient most of the key
stayed on get some of that that's good
yeah they're doing us to work uh yeah
absolutely yeah yeah
here's the top slightly bent
you could probably based on buffer
earlier get a little hammer tap it out
now interestingly there's a J written in
pen on the inside I'm not sure who wrote
that if you wrote it give us a bell you
know yeah listen as you write in here's
the screen remember at school when the
teacher you had days like transparencies
for the overhead projector looks like a
load of them I'm pretty sure that's
glass nice Sheen lovely I'm sorry Steve
Jobs I love you oh well that was a
rather violent end for an old map
probably still sell that for a couple
hundred quid yeah eBay good
who wants it anyone new stuff place your
bids below I'm gonna kid and don't do
that another look check out tomorrow